und zwar auch hier in berlin mein
kollege peter wg betritt gerade die
liebig 34 diese wurde heute morgen am
vormittag geräumt peter was genau
passiert da jetzt wir sind eben jetzt
hier in dem geräumten haus der lieblich
34 das bis heute morgen noch von 54
menschen 57 personen besetzt und können
uns hier das ausmaß der verwüstung
anschauen hier sehen wir wohl ein altes
waschbecken natürlich die hygienischen
zustände katastrophal eigentlich ist ein
noch ein müllhaufen ein alter ofen der
aber auch nicht mehr wirklich
funktionstüchtig aussieht bierkästen und
einfach in ein riesen ausmaß an
verwüstung hier wurde eine massive eine
massive falltür aus schwerste strafe
eingebaut die die polizei aber
notdürftig gesichert hat und zudem
gesagt aber dass wir an diesen pfeiler
zum beispiel überhaupt nicht stoßen
dürfen weil es halt immer noch gefährdet
ist dass es auf einen herabstürzen kann
was natürlich schwerste verletzungen
hervorrufen können hier sind wir jetzt
im treppenhaus wandmalereien aber
insgesamt auch hier baulich echt ein
ganz schlimmer zustand elektronik dass
dritte nicht also die beleuchtung geht
hier wohl auf jeden fall gar nicht mehr
hier können wir noch in die in die räume
hinein blicken die auch extrem verwüstet
aussehen also die wurde halt über jahre
war ja gar kein reinkommen war das haus
hier besetzt konnte konnten keine
bauarbeiten keine erneuerung vorgenommen
werden und das spiegelt sich jedoch
wieder
masturbation never break your heart
erst da gespielt und jetzt sind wir im
ersten obergeschoss wohl und könnt ihr
in einem raum dieser raum sieht sogar
verhältnismäßig noch ganz in ordnung
haus aber auch hier die sind sehen wir
dann
verpflegung die hier wohl gelagert
worden
preis also natürlich lange haltbare
nahrung die mit dem man über wochen
wahrscheinlich sich versorgen konnte da
hat man sich auf alles mögliche
vorbereitet die ihr möglichst lange
aussagen zu können und können jetzt auch
noch mal hier
hier sehen wir ja überall liegt hier der
dreck hier halt nudeln verteilt ist weil
und hier unten ein raum mit alten
fahrern die hier ja einfach
reingeschmissen eine also eine falle
wenn die polizisten hat durch die
fenster hinein kommt umgang das erstmal
in den in den alten fahrrädern zu landen
und sich womöglich wieder zu verletzen
und die zahlt die daran zu hindern
hierdurch dringend zu können jetzt
können wir hier noch weiter schauen
fliegen perücken da hier noch einen raum
der hier sind sie sehen wir wie die
fenster und die massiv auch züge sind
sehen wir stahlträger die da eingebaut
wurden einbetoniert in die wand davor
noch so holzlatten polizisten anzünden
sondern auch hier kann man sehen wie mit
stacheldraht und wieder auch diesen
diesen stahlstangen wieder in die wand
massiv eingetreten
hier ist die polizei auch wohl nicht
durch gelangt zu verhindern dass da
jemand eindringen konnte natürlich der
stacheldraht auch das verletzungsrisiko
für die putschisten hier auch eine sehen
wir eine stahltür die wohl in die wände
eingebaut war hier
hier haben dann wohl die besetzer
geschlafen dann sehen wir auch so
hygienisch absolut katastrophale
zustände
und auch mit wer hier noch noch massiver
als bereits vorhin schon wie hier die
fenster nach draußen zugemauert wurden
oder züge mit stahlgittern und anna hier
ist eine matte und nur noch gras das sei
noch heile geblieben aber auch eben
diese stahlträger die hier eingebaut
wurden um ein durchkommen unmöglich zu
machen
[Musik]
hier sind
enorme verwüstung auch hier das wurden
die ganzen räume vollgeladen mit müll wo
auch dann kein durchkommen war
[Musik]
auch hier ist wieder da fernseher alte
also extremst viel sperrmüll der hier
hier ist dann natürlich kann das
permanent hier sehen wird wie die profis
also hier haben wir den raum voll
geladen und das ist eben das fenster was
wir gesehen haben von draußen auf den
ganzen bildern im ersten stock über das
die polizei dann hier rhein gelangt ist
hier haben sie halt diese stahlträger
die überall fest betoniert worden
beck geflext und konnten dann über die
treppe die wir in den vielen bildern
gesehen haben die rhein gelangt und
haben sich dann halt von hier schritt
für schritt durch das haus vorgearbeitet
von raum zu raum mussten ja wie wir auch
so auf zugigen gesehen haben ganten
betonwände durchschlagen um halt die
räume nach den personen abzusuchen ist
auch vorzustellen dass sich die besetzer
dann wohl hier hinter diesem ganzen müll
bergen versteckt haben wo sie natürlich
auf den ersten blick erstmal gar nicht
zu erkennen sind also also sehen wir
hier was für eine riesige arbeit das für
die polizei wie sehr muss das tier als
abzusuchen enorme verwüstungen und ja
damit zurück ins studio hier aus dem
besetzten haus in der liebigstraße
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren